[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hi there.
Welcome to Route 85.
So happy you could join us.
Now for today, I'd like
to show you my fantastic
new app sure to race its way up
the charts called Tickle Lift.
It stars my little
square friend here.
I think I'm going
to call him Teddy.
Hi, Teddy.
Now, using a
standard pan gesture,
I can pick Teddy up
and drag him around.
Oh, look at him fall.
Don't worry, he'll be fine.
He has his good
health insurance.
But now using a
custom tickle gesture,
I can move my finger back
and forth to tickle him.
Teddy turns pink and
giggles, and then he
notifies HR because this
is inappropriate behavior
at the workplace.
But wait, you say.
How am I able to have both a
pan gesture drag Teddy around
while also supporting
a tickle gesture?
How come Teddy isn't moving
around left to right when
I tickle him?
Well, that leads us to
this episode's quick tip,
sent in by Ronny Rozen,
founder and CEO of poccaDot.
Ronny writes that when
you create a gesture,
you can designate a class
to serve as that gesture's
UIGestureRecognizerDelegate.
One of these delegate methods
is gestureRecognizerShouldBegin.
In this delegate method,
you can analyze the gesture
and return yes or
no depending on
whether or not you want
that gesture to switch
to a begin state.
In Tickle Drop, for instance,
my gestureRecognizerShouldBegin
call first looks to see if the
gesture recognizer being passed
in is a pan gesture recognizer.
If it is, then my
delegate method
checks to see if the
user is panning upwards
and that they're mostly panning
in a vertical direction.
If both of these
things are true,
this method will return true.
And otherwise it, won't.
And then I can return true for
any other gesture recognizer.
So if I start dragging my
finger sideways across Teddy,
my gestureRecognizerShouldBegin
delegate method
sees that this is a
mostly horizontal gesture,
and it returns false for
my pan gesture recognizer,
leaving other
gesture recognizers,
such as my tickle one, free
to respond to that touch.
Now, I'm sure you could think
of other areas besides just
tickling things where you
might be able to take advantage
of this technique.
Maybe you have a tap
gesture or a pan gesture
that's only valid if I touch
the top half of a view.
Or maybe you have
a pinch gesture
that only activates if
I'm pinching inwards
or if I'm pinching in
at a particular speed.
And so if you combine
this delegate method
with some of these other
crazy delegate methods here,
you can get some pretty
sophisticated touch behavior.
So I asked around, and
there are a few places
where we use gesture
recognizer delegate methods,
including our
gestureRecognizerDidBegin one.
One example is the
Google Photos app,
which consists of three
vertical scroll views inside
of a horizontal one.
Now typically in
setups like this,
you won't be able to
swipe horizontally
until you've stopped
scrolling vertically.
Well, the team found that
kind of awkward to use,
particularly when you've
got a huge list of photos
that you're scrolling
through all the time.
So they addressed this, first
by allowing two pan gestures
at once with the
gestureRecognizer
shouldRecognizeS
imultaneouslyWit
hGestureRecognizer
method, and then
only recognizing horizontal pans
for the horizontal UIScrollView
in the
gestureRecognizerShouldBegin
method.
And now I've got
a photos app where
I can scroll through
all my photos,
but also swipe
horizontally at any time.
Look at that.
Isn't that nice?
So thanks again, Ronny,
for sending in that tip.
As a thank you, she will be
getting this very stylish
Google t-shirt.
Also shout out to the iOS
tutorial site raywenderlich.com
for their very nice tutorial
on how to write your own custom
tickle gesture.
Go check it out.
But what about the rest of you?
Jealous that you
didn't get a t-shirt?
Don't be.
Just email me your own
quick tip at this address.
If you do and I
use it on the air,
I will send a
t-shirt to you too.
How easy is that?
So thanks for watching, and I
will see you soon on Route 85.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey Todd?
I've gotten three
reports from HR
that you've been
tickling your co-workers.
Is that true?
TODD KERPELMAN: You see, there's
a really simple explanation
for this.
You see, look out behind you!
MALE SPEAKER: Huh?
I can still see you.
TODD KERPELMAN: No you can't.
I'm hiding.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah, I can.